MIMIEJAD FOR A SHOT AND
HE SCORES! CIRCLE.
DEVILS ARE ON IT. THE
SLOT.
REBOUND.BLE BRAUN ABLE TO PLAY
AHEAD.
SET ACROSS THE GOAL THE MISSED.
THREE ON ONE THE OTHER WAY.
HUGHES OVER THE LI LONE ASSIST .
HERE ISTTLE MORE THAN 3 TO GO, E
DOUBLE MINOR
CHRISTIAN JARI. THE BOX. ARE MI
T.J.
OSHIE TONIGHT
SO CARLSON WILL DOWN, OR WAS BU
AND NOW THE
>>Craig: A TOUGH COUPLE OF
SHIFTSS FOR T, DIVING PLAY AS S.
HERE'S FAULK, UNLOADS ITTHERE.
IT.ES THE HIT FROM
CAPS DESPERATE NOW DOWN BY A
PAIR.  HAVING A LITTLE
TROUBLE.
STEPPING INTO THEIR ZONE, A STI
THAT.
ITAND PLACE IT
HURRICANES SCRAMBLE A CHANGE.
NIKITA KUCHEROV WITH THE PUCK S
JUST WENT WIDE.
TWO HIP  -- ITD
THATTHE TROPHY THIS YEAR.
GOODNG FOR
TYLER TO MAKE HIS
TO ATKINSON. AND WE'LL HAVE BOT
GAMES FOR YOU ON BALLY SPORTSSSL
AND MAYFIEN
FRONT.
IT COMES TO LEE, AND HE SCORES!.
ZACH PAR
EHLERS, GETS DOUBLE TO PWHE
LIYU
EXCELLENT.
STASTNY CALMING PRESENCE AS HE
KIND OF DOES THE RIGHT THING. KD
D
SHORTHANDED.
HE IS IN.
AND THAT WAS CHIPPED JUST SHOT,K
RYAN.
ANOTHER SHOT.
THAT WAS--
HINTZ!
DALLAS HAS TIED IT ACROSS!
SCORED!
AND IT'S DRAISAITL FOR!
JUST LIKE THAT, THE STARS E ICE
IN!
EMPTY-THAT  GOOD NEWS FOR THE
OPPONENTS BECAUSE THEIR POWER
PLAYS REALLY GOODD IT WENT IN
MARC-EDOUARD VLASIC SENS ONE
PUTS THE PUCK IN DEEP.
MEIER!
AND THEYRABANOV.
END UP ON MEIER'S STICK.
HERTL IN FRONT, BARABANOV.
DENIED
WENNBERG LINE OUT.
SOUCY SCORES.ON'T HAVE A LOT OF
GOING ON.
COYOTES GET THE FIRST GOAL AND
ICE SCHWARTZ. SCORES!
DOUBLE DOWN, CARSON  McCANN.
WHO DROPS IT OFF FOR KOLE LIND.
McCANN, ALL THE WAY ACROSS, IT'S
ADRIAN KEMPE HE SCORES.MOORE WI
SCORING HAND AND THE KINGS ARE
THE ROOKIE WINS THE CONNECTS WI.
L.A.
HAS REGAINED ITS
KEMPE